the results we can now show you
pre-election opinion poll suggested that
the political order here was about to be
turned on its head this exit poll
suggests it has been turned on its head
and shaken up and down the two
center-right parties FINA Foyle and FINA
Gale which have jointly dominated Irish
politics for nearly a century have been
matched by shin Fane each polling 22% of
first preference votes and what that
means essentially is that the party has
been making gains and is now
consolidated those gains over the last
number of years so they're in a strong
position going forward not necessarily
to form a government this time right
there only one running 42 candidates but
certainly for the next election they're
in a very good position the buzzword of
this election campaign was change
Ireland's economy maybe the fastest
growing in EU but people here are
struggling with soaring house prices and
years long waiting lists for public
health care voters were just fed up with
the two main parties alternatives to
feel again the fina fall so I didn't
really want to go independent but
basically just some kind of alternative
Sudeste just quote about what the future
is going to hold for me with climate
change and how that's going to affect my
life in the future
chin vein is the left wing nationalists
republican party previously regarded as
the political wing of the paramilitary
group the IRA now shedding those
associations and remoulding itself as a
progressive alternative and it's not
clear what shin famed strategy will be
now looking at it from the outside I
think they would benefit from not going
into government in this occasion because
they would be going in as a junior
partner to FINA fall or FINA Gale and
previous experience of junior partners
with those parties suggests that they
would lose votes non political factors
may also influence the outcome of this
election it's the first Saturday poll
since 1918 storm Keira brought dangerous
winds and driving rain to many polling
stations and slap-bang in the middle of
polling day a major rugby international
the timing of this election certainly
raised eyebrows I can't believe that it
is really
but it's important we vote and have you
voted already know you're mad that game
is more important to voting I'm sorry
under the Irish system transfer votes
will be crucial how many second and
third preferences can the big parties
pick up
but even if Shin Fame doesn't get into a
government the days of two-party
dominance in this country appear to be
over Paul Brennan al-jazeera Dublin